aus dem gefängnis entlassen der blogger
rief al-baradei doch wirklich frei ist
er nicht nach zehn jahren haft darf der
saudi-arabische menschenrechtsaktivist
zehn weitere jahre das land nicht
verlassen kann seine frau und kinder die
in kanada leben nicht wiedersehen bilder
aus vergangenen zeiten
zeitgleich mit der freilassung von bary
gibt der saudische königreich etwas
bekannt deswegen des ukraine krieges von
der weltöffentlichkeit fast unbemerkt
blieb
kriminelle gruppen haben den pfad der
wahrheit verlassen und gehen jetzt den
weg des lasters und des teufels
das saudiarabische innenministerium
meldet am 12 märz 2022 die hinrichtung
von 81 menschen eine der größten
massenhinrichtungen in der geschichte
des landes die beschuldigten seien wegen
unterschiedlicher verbrechen zum tode
verurteilt worden wegen mitgliedschaft
bei terrororganisationen wegen mordes
andere wegen teilnahme an protesten und
sitzstreiks sowie störung des nationalen
zusammenhalts
für den islamwissenschaftler guido
steinberg versucht kronprinz salman
regimekritiker in seinem land mit dem
vorwurf des terrorismus zu
kriminalisieren auch um die todesurteile
in der westlichen welt salonfähig zu
machen
saudi arabien hat in den letzten jahren
immer wieder die erfahrung gemacht dass
die westliche welt zwar zunächst einmal
mit
sehr kritisch reagiert wenn menschen
hingerichtet werden aber saudi arabien
weiß auch welche argumente ziehen und
deswegen werden all diejenigen die dort
getötet werden als terroristen
bezeichnet und die meisten opfer sind
wohl tatsächlich schiiten bei denen
überhaupt nicht klar ist ob sie denn
überhaupt eine organisierte
oppositionsgruppe angehören wo bei denen
nicht klar ist ob sie gewalt angewendet
haben und bei denen sogar der verdacht
besteht dass es eher friedliche
demonstranten sind die dort bestraft
werden auch für amnesty international
steht nach untersuchungen fest dass
viele der angeklagten zum tode
verurteilt wurden nur weil sie frei ihre
meinung geäußert und ein versammlungen
oppositioneller teilgenommen hatten
in einigen fällen die wir dokumentiert
haben wurden menschen wegen ihrer
beteiligung an demonstrationen zum tode
verurteilt auch weil sie andere
motiviert haben sollen an den protesten
teilzunehmen was natürlich nicht
kriminalisiert werden sollte oder gar
ein anklagepunkt sein dürfte
kriminalisiert wird auch er der
religiöse reformer hassan al maliki
anhänger eines moderaten und
aufgeklärten islam in diesen tagen wird
ihm der prozess gemacht
die staatsanwaltschaft hat seine
hinrichtung verlangt für anklagepunkte
die empören sind wie zum beispiel der
besitz von bestimmten büchern
weil er in zeitungen und
fernsehinterviews erschienen ist in
medien geht dem königreich feindlich
gesinnt seien
alles anklagepunkte die gemeinde
freiheit kriminalisieren
er muss jetzt mit der todesstrafe
rechnen
archaische scharia strafen in einem land
das in schwindelerregendem tempo an die
moderne anschließt das nach jahrzehnten
kinos und rockkonzerte zulässt frauen
erlaubt alleine zu reisen die
geschlechtertrennung sukzessive auf hit
ein königreich das eine deutliche
liberalisierung im gesellschaftlichen
leben voran treibt die aber keineswegs
mit einer liberalisierung des
politischen lebens einhergeht
im gegenteil alle fäden laufen bei einem
übermächtigen autokraten zusammen der je
nach gutdünken freiheiten gewährt oder
auch nimmt
beispiel die frauenrechtsaktivistin
luzia hassel fast drei jahre saß sie im
gefängnis unter anderem weil sie gegen
das fahrverbot für frauen protestiert
hatte doch kurz nach ihrer verhaftung
erlaubte bentheim an den frauen das
autofahren und es zeigt sich immer
wieder dass der kronprinzen nicht bereit
ist
oppositionellen oder auch reform man
in irgendeiner weise das anrecht
einzuräumen zu symbolen für diese
reformen zu werden er will die reform
anordnen er will nicht dass es so
aussieht als seien reformen ein erfolg
von irgendwelchen oppositionellen
denkern oder aktivisten
mit unerbittlicher härte geht wenzelmann
gegen erklärte regierungskritiker vor
verbreitet mit willkürlichen
hinrichtungen angst und schrecken die
geständnisse der 81 zum tode
verurteilten sowohl nach auskunft von
human rights watch als auch von amnesty
international zum großen teil durch
folter erzwungen
nach den gerichtsakten zu urteilen die
wir analysiert haben wissen wir dass die
von uns untersuchten fälle keinen zugang
zu einem irgendwie gearteten rechtlichen
beistand während ihrer untersuchungshaft
hatten die verurteilten hatten dem
gericht gesagt dass sie gefoltert und
dass ihre geständnisse erzwungen worden
sei
sie hatten nach medizinischer
untersuchung verlangt die ihnen
verweigert wurde
die menschenrechtsverletzungen die
todesurteile ignorieren der britische
premierminister boris johnson muss ich
diesen vorwurf jedenfalls gefallen
lassen wenige tage nach den
massenhinrichtungen reiste er vor dem
hintergrund des ukraine krieges zu einem
der größten öllieferanten der welt zu
bentheim an soll er auch persönlich
einen sehr guten draht haben
vorrangiges interesse natürlich wenn die
leitungen zu russland gekappt werden
müssen neue energiequellen erschlossen
werden und saudi arabien weiß das und
man muss dann wirklich dazu sagen dass
auch die auch die proteste nach der
letzten hinrichtung schwelle anfang 2016
beispielsweise doch sehr sehr schnell
abgeebbt sind also saudi arabien hat die
erfahrung gemacht dass der westen das
königreich ganz einfach braucht und dass
dann solche hinrichtungen längerfristig
auch nicht schaden
unvorstellbar angesichts des
unermesslichen leids dass diese
hinrichtungen über die 81 oft
unschuldigen opfer und ihre familien
gebracht haben
[Musik]